welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and Joker is a film designed to be
up for interpretation by its audience
and not the interpretation some critics
would to have you believe that people
don't kill people that Joker movie kills
people boiler warning if you have not
seen Joker yet okay the interpretation
debate focuses on the film's ending
which poses that much of the film's
narrative could have been a false
account of an incarcerated mentally
disturbed man director Todd Phillips
confirmed to the LA Times that he was
inspired by the Joker graphic novel The
Killing Joke which depicted the Joker's
origin as they failed comedian and
included the mysterious line and I'm
going to have a past I prefer it to be
multiple choice and Phillips leaned into
that concept with his film saying that
the movie is quote less you being kind
of presented with the facts then you
being presented with these possibilities
but within this broader mystery over
what exactly is and is not real in this
narrative there's a narrower mystery
within that narrative the question of
Arthur flex parentage the film poses a
subplot that first suggests that Arthur
is the illegitimate son of Thomas Wayne
father of Bruce Wayne which would make
Joker Batman then that claim appears to
be dismissed shortly after with Arthur
learning from medical records that he
was adopted and that his mother was
mentally ill as well but then there's a
very subtle moment right before the
film's final act that if you caught it
actually changes the entire paternity
narrative and suggests that within
Arthur flex maybe fictional narrative
Thomas Wayne a lyin liar who lies
orchestrated and insane cover-up to hide
Batman's brother from the world let us
investigate this deception in this
episode of and before I dive into this
conspiracy if you plan to attend la
Comic Con the host of new rock stars
will be hosting a panel there Saturday
October 12 at 3 p.m. come meet us there
and ask us all your deeper questions and
see how deep this conspiracy rabbit hole
can go okay early in the Joker film
Arthur's mother penny Fleck a former
employee of Thomas Wayne mentions having
written letters to Thomas that he will
not answer later Arthur reads one of
those letters and sees that she wrote to
Thomas saying Arthur was his son and
that she and Thomas had an affair and
that Arthur was a product of that but
when Arthur visits the way in the state
and gives young Batman a taste for clown
fingers younger Alfred Pennyworth comes
out of the gate and
denies that there was ever any affair
but if you'll notice when Alfred
approaches Arthur he says in so many
words Oh y'all has son it suggests that
he's at least vaguely familiar with
penny Fleck
and likely that he has read to some of
those letters and then maybe even he
could be involved somehow Arthur then
confronts Thomas Wayne in the bathroom
at a charity event where Thomas also
denies that they're related then Arthur
says look at us I think we are an
interesting response because obviously
Joaquin Phoenix and Brett Cullen look
nothing alike
but you know with movies we always
suspend our disbelief that actors who
look nothing alike are just cast as
parent and child but Arthur to call it
out like this seems odd we're going to
say it kind of suggests that we're
either meant to doubt him in the
authenticity of this entire narrative
that Arthur Fleck just sees the world
through his different eyes that are at
odds with our objective reality or that
from Arthur's perspective the
perspective that we're seeing this
entire story from these two men actually
do look alike and we're just supposed to
go along with that Thomas tells our
third that he never had an affair with
penny that she claimed Arthur was his
son but that she actually adopted Arthur
Thomas said that she was mentally ill
and spent some time at Arkham state
hospital and Thomas's claims seems to be
confirmed when Arthur checks Penny's
medical history at Arkham state hospital
and finds a net file paperwork
confirming that she did adopt Arthur and
that she even allowed a past boyfriend
to abuse Arthur as a kid but all of this
paperwork was signed off by a man named
dr. Benjamin stoner which actually
should raise some red flags and not just
because Thea name itself Benjamin I'm
going to explain why this name is so
important but before I get to view huge
thanks to Cove audio for sponsoring this
episode so I've been using coves
commuter Bluetooth speaker and I
freaking love it just listen to how loud
it can get it's a bit loud I know yes
all you do is you just connect your
Bluetooth and you let it blast while I'm
cooking or tabletop gaming with friends
or assembly new furniture after I lose
the tabletop game and smash my furniture
with friends and then angrily trying to
assemble new furniture because I don't
speak Swedish really anytime I want to
break from headphones and I want a super
loud speaker to cover my frustrated
roars I can usually run it on a single
charge which gets you up to eight
it's water-resistant and it has indoor
and outdoor equalizer modes so you'll
have the best sound no matter where you
are in your kitchen or like blowing off
steam outside it has this touch slider
and tactile volume function to give you
complete control over your swipe and in
addition to this quality Cove is one of
the most affordable speakers out there
because we are giving you guys a special
discount of 65% off just click on our
link below Cove audio comm slash rock 65
okay
dr. Benjamin stoner is an actual
character from the DC Comics the former
head psychiatrist at Arkham Asylum later
becomes the villain anti theta battling
the DC hero dr. fate so Benjamin stoner
is a lesser known DC villain but he is
not a good guy oh wow I don't think this
Joker film is setting up a doctor fate
spin-off I do think the negative
connotation around Benjamin stoner
combined with Thomas Waynes political
aspirations in a tallit ism and the way
he looks down on the working class are
more than enough to call into question
the authenticity of these medical
reports Thomas Waynes historical past is
that of a career physician with this
man's immense wealth his resources his
connections with powerful figures and
medical professionals how hard would it
really be for him to falsify medical
reports to cover up a scandal especially
with the help of a body man who used to
work for British intelligence and then
if this isn't enough right as the movie
transitions into its third act after
Arthur kills his mother he sits in their
apartment and finds an old photograph of
her on the back is a written message
love your smile T W holy [ __ ] Arthur's
father is Tiger Woods now seriously
though if Thomas Wayne truly had no
relationship with penny pike this
probably wouldn't exist right and if
this movie wanted us to think that the
medical history it previously presented
about penny was the real truth it
definitely would not show us this
disputing evidence so this is designed
to call into question everything we have
just been told about Thomas Wayne and
the fact that this love note was quote
love your smile is even more on the nose
Arthur's whole identity is based around
his smile in his lap this moment is
meant to suggest to us that that smile
was inherited from one man in particular
but whatever answered
Thomas Wayne gets from maury povich his
films whole narrative is unreliable
Arthur flex final scene in the mental
ward matches the setting from the
flashback earlier in the film when he
pounded his head against the wall his
hair and that final scene doesn't appear
to have green dye in it when we
definitely saw him die his hair green
earlier his relationship with Sophie was
all imaginary his early appearance in
the studio audience of live with Murray
Franklin was a flight of fancy some of
you even pointed out that all the clocks
in the movie are at the time 11:11 the
time one traditionally makes a wish
suggesting this is all his dream
backstory or that this movie is now
connected to Jordan peels us now that's
gonna be a total conspiracy so why does
this question of Thomas Wayne's
paternity even matter if this is all
fictional anyway well the fact that
Arthur could conceive this drama as part
of his fantasy gives us insight into
this Joker's mind people who believe in
conspiracy type thinking don't find
their truth in the simplest explanation
of events their truth is always more
complicated dramatic filled with
deception and cover-ups
they cannot embrace a boring reality so
naturally when Arthur Fleck is supposed
to tell one of the narratives of his
multiple choice backstory it makes sense
that his dream scenario would be that
his insanity could have been inherited
by the same man who bore his arch enemy
Arthur finds the most delightful fiction
to be one in which he is a neglected
abused bastard son of the corrupt King
one whom the King tried to hide in shame
but failed as a bastard son became the
court jester who got vengeance against
his estranged father turned the kingdom
upside down and crowned himself the
Clown Prince of Crime a fantasy that
really only makes sense to a madman
because it's a too much comments down
below with your thoughts on this follow
me on instagram and twitter at a boss
and subscribe to new rock stars or more
total conspiracy investigations thank
you for watching and you know there
probably are a few kids out there
wondering if Tiger Woods is their dad
[Music]